une petite photo pour replacer à
l'identique pendant la demi-heure qui va
suivre flavien va prendre soin de cette
sépulture au cimetière de maurepas ici
reposent les proches d'une famille
francilienne cette sépulture en fait ça
fait à peu près trois ans qu'on
intervient sur ce dossier interne ne
meurent pas un visage et ça comme ça
c'est une famille qui fait appel à nos
services tous les mois donc vous
passerons tous les mois entretenir
fleurir la sépulture en fonction des
fleurs qu'ils ont souhaité le plan
dispose sur la sépulture avec un associé
ils ont fondé une société spécialisée en
2008 basées dans les bouches du rhône
une demande des clients liés à
l'éloignement des familles ou de
descendants âgées on a le sentiment que
les familles ont de plus en plus besoin
de préserver la mémoire de leurs proches
a disparu internet il ya beaucoup pour
cela puisque aujourd'hui effectivement
beaucoup plus facile et j'ai envie de
dire que sociologiquement les gens sont
plus aptes à acheter des prestations de
services à distance
l'entreprise pratique environ dix mille
interventions par an l'entretien d'une
sépulture est obligatoire et une
concession abandonné peut être prise par
la mairie